une bonne nouvelle à présent pour les
passagers de la ligne du rer c plusieurs
rames de la ligne c'était décorée aux
couleurs du château de versailles comme
vous le voyez sur ces images c'est la
quatrième année que la sncf et le
château de travail d'ensemble pour faire
rêver les franciliens mais aussi les
touristes lors de leur trajet pour
l'instant deux rames sont décorées trois
autres le seront en début d'année
prochaine écoutez catherine pégard la
directrice du château à était au micro
de nicolas kirillovitch
nous on a deux objectifs que s'il s'agit
des touristes les touristes qui viennent
à versailles ils commencent leur visite
et ils rêvent de versailles avant d'y
arriver et le soir quand ils repartent
ils gardent le souvenir de versailles
est un peu plus longtemps en prenant le
train et pour tous ceux qui prennent le
rer en effet pour aller à leur travail
je pense que ça peut outre le fait que
ça leur donne une atmosphère apaisée je
pense aussi que ça peut leur donner
l'idée de revenir à vinça et devenir
revisité vers celles qu'ils connaissent
déjà